Americans wrote an estimated 80 billion
pounds of food every year tourist
destinations like Las Vegas with its
reputation for excess are part of the
problem but now one hotel group is using
technology to preserve leftover food
from good use John Blackstone shows us
how meals that would have gone to pig
farms or landfills are now helping feed
the hungry the Las Vegas that most
visitors see is glittering and opulent a
city where there seems to be more than
enough of everything especially food in
a lavish banquet room at the Aria hotel
lunch is being served to 1300 people
attending a convention but away from the
Vegas Strip get ready to open up the
doors of feed the passes the dining room
at Catholic Charities serves those who
don't have enough food we serve a free
meal to anyone who needs a deacon Tom
Roberts is CEO there's probably more
food consumed in Las Vegas per capita
than any other place in the world in
here we serve a thousand people every
day in this kitchen the numbers frankly
are astounding
since 2007 much of the leftover food
from MGM's Las Vegas hotels has been
used to feed pigs llaman Siddiqui is the
vice president of sustainability for MGM
Resorts a better use is to feed people
but there's some challenges in doing
that sure the process to collect surplus
banquet food is complicated but we think
it's something worth figuring out
complicated because food safety
regulations require leftover banquet
food to be delivered immediately for
safe consumption but now MGM Resorts has
found a way to keep their excess food
safe for much longer as soon as a
banquet is finished food that has been
prepared but not served is transferred
and loaded onto a truck from 3 square a
Las Vegas Food Bank once it arrives
there it's flash-frozen in a high-tech
refrigerator called a blast chiller
and move to the freezer the food can be
saved for up to three months sent when
needed to places like the Catholic
Charities dining room this program is
absolutely going to help reduce food
insecurity in this city at scale
Siddiqui says they hope other Las Vegas
hotels will follow their example what's
in it for MGM well this program is one
that we believe in one of the things we
get out of this program is the ability
to tell our major convention clients
that we are doing this they say the
program could help divert 1 million
pounds of food by 2020 to feed the
hungry when life turned bad for Andy who
stack a few months ago he arrived at the
dining room with six dollars in his
pocket were you hungry then all boy was
I and even in two days never been under
in my life I came in here I got a hot
meal I got a box I got a shower
excuse me but
next I got involved in a program and as
they say the rest is history
what isn't needed in a hotel banquet
room can help change lives when it's
served to someone who does need it for
CBS this morning John Blackstone Las
Vegas
very nice John Blackstone you see the
difference it makes you could see by the
emotion on that man and it's good that
somebody is eating the food I know I've
always thought about that the buffets
have so much just throw the stuff out
that's good